Hi everyone, I'm Travis.
Hello, I'm Yang Jong. I'm Jan. And we're
here to talk to you today about the end
of awkward AI transcripts from
Nvidia. So, what we're going to go over
today is basically how we develop models
at NVIDIA speech um for NVIDIA speech
AI. We're going to go over the model
architectures, um our main approach to
how we develop models for our customer
base, um the entire development process,
and our focus on deployment and
customization. So, who are we? Well,
we're with Nvidia Repo. We focus on
enterprise level um speech AI model
deployment. We cover speech translation,
text to speech development, speech
recognition, speech translation,
basically everything so that um we can
at an enterprise level allow customers
to provide the best possible
conversational AI that is possible and
we our focus is generally on low
latency, highly efficient models that
can be used um on embedded devices.
So um at NVIDIA there's generally like
four categories we focus on when we're
thinking about model development. First
is robustness. Are our models going to
work in noisy environments as well as it
work in clean environments? What type of
sound quality are we trying to meet? Are
we going to worry about telefan? Are we
going to worry about a bunch of
environmental contamination factors? Um
we also consider ourselves with
coverage. What are the domains that our
customer base wants? Is it going to be
medical? Is it going to be
entertainment? Is it going to be um just
straight up call centerbased? What is
the language demands that we need? Do we
want to focus on monilingual development
or multilingual development? How will
dialect play into our model cases? And
is there a pro problem of code switching
that we should accommodate for in
development? We also focus on
personalization. We want to make sure
that our customers are able to have the
exact model that they need for their
needs. Sometimes we got to focus on
target speaker AI. Sometimes we got to
focus on word boosting for uncommon
vocabulary. Sometimes we just get down
and dirty with old-fashioned text
normalization FST models just to make
sure that you're getting the exact
output you want. And then finally, we
focus on deployment cases. How does
speed and accuracy trade off here? which
is more important or do we want a middle
ground of the two? Um do we want our
models to be have high variety or are we
going to focus on efficiency and kind of
leave like um the Swiss army knives in
in our back
pocket. So what type of models do we use
to accomplish this? Well, if you're from
a speech AI background, a lot of this is
really familiar stuff. First off, we
still rely on the oldfashioned CTC
models because we keep finding that
non-auto regression um decoding cases is
really optimal if you need high-speed
inference, especially in streaming
environments where you can just run CTC
over a um chunk data set, use that as a
streaming model and you can move on with
your next
project. But of course, we still like
high accuracy. So when we find that just
simply not on aggression is not um a
ideal then we rely on the oldfashioned
R&T or um you use TDT models which is a
variant um developed at Nvidia. Here
we've used the audio output of an
encoder with an internal LM so that we
can have auto reggressive streaming
setups um for
deployment. Then sometimes you want even
more accuracy. Sometimes you don't want
to worry about streaming in which case
we also offer um attention encoder
decoder setups. We are all familiar with
them at this point. Whisper chat GBT LLM
and yeah we offer this here. We find
that they're really good if you want a
highly accurate model um with less focus
on alignment and more importantly
accommodate a lot of ta tasks within a
single model. We find um auto um we find
transformer decoders really great when
you need to incorporate speech
translation, timestamp prediction,
language identification, and speech
recognition all within a single model
with simple prompt
changes. But across all of our different
um decoding platforms, we have one
unifying tool, which is that our
fundamental architecture is the fast
conformer. Through a lot of empirical
trials, we found that the original
conformer model can be even greatly um
subsampled so that instead of just the
conventional 40 millisecond timest step
compression, you can switch you can add
in a ne another step of subsampling and
get 80 millisecond compression. And we
find that along with allowing you to
have very small audio inputs and thus
really lightens your memory load on
training, it also makes training a lot
more efficient because you can get way
quicker convergence with um not as much
data as needed. Further, it allows
really fast inference because now you're
chunking all your data into just 80
millisecond time steps. And so we found
that this is a really strong
architecture that we have at the
backbone of all of our previous um
decoding
offerings. And this allows us to split
our model offerings into two options. On
the left we have Reva parakeet which is
focused on our streaming speech
recognition cases and this is where we
put our CTC and our TDT models. And the
focus is on streaming. If you want
speech recognition, speech
translation, target speaker ASR, you're
going to run it through a parakeet model
so that you can have very fast um and
efficient um recognition. Meanwhile, on
our other option, we have Rea Canary,
which is where we put our fast conformer
models. This is where we focus on
accuracy and mult and multitask
modeling. This is where we're going to
get the best accuracy as possible while
not really caring that much about speed.
Though we do push for strong
speed. And so be able to cover all this,
we get a really really comprehensive
toolkit in which we can offer to our
customers um a mixture of fast
multitasking or high accuracy models.
And most important is that our focus on
we have the model to meet the need as
opposed to an idea that one model fits
all. We focus on variety and coverage
rather than um unifying and um keeping
everything under one hood.
Given the success of the parakeet ASR
model, it can be easily extended to the
multis speaker and target speaker uh
scenario with the integration of the
derization model former. The softformer
is a end to end neuron doriser that
following the rival timeing principle in
the simply words is standing for who
comes first. So the softformer behaves
as a bridge between the speaker time
stamp from the derization and the
speaker token that can be recognized by
the ASR model. In our mo in our model
architecture development principle, we
fuse the ASR encoder embedding and the
softformer embedding through the speaker
kernel in providing the full-fledged who
spoke what and when problem and this
objective this model can be fine-tuned
with the really simple objective similar
to the any ASR model training uh
perspective and also by feeding the
model or feeding the model with the
optional Cory audio or not, we can make
the model to conduct the target speaker
ASR task or the single multis speaker
ASR task. And moreover, our unified
model architecture consists of ASR
encoding software, but it can not only
be applied in the parallel joint manner,
but can also be used as a cascade system
just like conventional multisspeaker
system.
Yeah. Uh we have additional models we
offer to improve border accuracy
customization and
readability. Um the voice activity
detection VA uh detect speech segments
for better noise robustness and we offer
this V and the Marbleet based V models.
The external language model uh resource
ASL transcription for better accuracy
and customization. We have engram based
language models uh in our uh the rea
pipelines. Text normalization and the
inverse text normalization converts
spoken terms to uh written forms in text
for better readability. And we have uh
the WFSD based ITN models. Punctuation
capitalization PNC uh add punctuation
and capitalization to the transcription
for better readability. and the board
based PNC models is
supported. Uh finally the speakeration
identifies uh multiple speakers in
conversation. Uh and we have the zoo for
based speaker direction models uh in
cascade model as well as the uh upcoming
for the uh end to end uh
models. And so, um, given this level of
customization, it doesn't like really
surprise that like it pays off, um, when
it comes to, um, rankings. Um, the
Hugging Face Open ASR leaderboard, the
majority of the top five models do come
from Nvidia, and all of it does is come
down to this approach on a focus on
customization and
variety. But, you know, rankings aren't
everything. So, let's try out a demo.
So, let's say you're trying to run a
recognition system, but you have a but
it's a song you're going over. Can our
models work? Living for the now. Long as
time allows. I'mma keep on switching
different styles. Keep creative on a
cloud. Sweat is on my brow cuz I'm
running on these tracks just to keep
them running back. You know the drill
back and I've been practicing my craft.
Dedicate this to Kobe. What could be a
bigger legacy to
Yeah, seems to work pretty well.
accurate transcription even in a noisy
setting. Okay, so that's our
architectures, that's our approach to
development. So how does it actually go
into training? Is there anything special
we do with training to um to meet this
demand? And the answer is honestly not
really. We really focus on the the
fundamentals when it comes to data
development. Like many labs, um, our
focus is on robustness when it comes to
sourcing data, multilingual coverage, an
ear for dialect sensitivity. We try and
get as much language documentation as
possible before um, so that we know
exactly what type of data spans we want
to get. We incorporate both open source
and proprietary data with the former
allowing us to focus on variety and
domain shift while the latter allows us
to focus on high quality entity data. We
incorporate pseudo labeling where we use
um the top-of-the-line models that are
available for commercial use and we take
transcripts from them allowing us to
benefit from further developments in the
community and further developments from
our own releases.
And then for training again a lot of it
is just standard available stuff. Um the
Nemo research um toolkit that is used
for our model training is an open source
available um library available for
anyone in the community to use. It's um
it's tools for GPU maximalization, data
bucketing, um high-speed data loading
through the Latte backend, all available
for just general use. And so we just
focus on this approach where we can
maximize our data. We can maximize the
um speed in which we can ingest data
across different settings. Most of our
data is in stored on a object store
infrastructure in which we can quickly
migrate between different cluster
settings. And then for validation, just
as much as with training, we focus on a
nice mixture of coverage in both open
source and proprietary data. We make
sure that by the time
data by the time our models actually
reach end users, we've gone through as
much um bias and domain testing as
possible across all possible language
categories just to make sure that our
models are as robust as possible.
The train model uh is now deployed to uh
Nvidia Reva through Nvidia Nim for low
latency and high throughput inference.
The high performance uh inference is
powered by Nvidia Tensor
optimizations. Um and the Nvidia Triton
inference server and it is available for
gRPC based microser for low latency
streaming as well as the high throughput
offline use cases. The Nvidia Reva is
fully containerized and it can uh easily
scale to hundreds of the um the par
streams and uh it can be run on prem in
any cloud at the edge or uh embedded
platforms to support a variety of the
applications including contact centers,
consumer applications and video
conferencing.
NVIDIA NIM offers pre-built container
industry standard API support for custom
models uh and optimized inference
engines. So one of the pain point in
real scenarios from customers is um
customization because every case um uh
every application requires domain
knowledge including the medical terms in
medical use case um menu names in food
ordering and um some of the conditions
telephonic uh and no environment in
contact centers. So Nvidia uh
reversers um the uh customization
features at every stages. So uh we can
fine-tune our acoustic model from the
parakeet based model canary based models
and then we can fine-tune the engram um
external language model punctuation
model and the inverse text normalization
models and also we offer the word
boosting to uh recognize uh better on
some of the uh product names jargon and
context specific uh knowledges.
So um we are offering our uh the reva
models in Nvidia name. So um you can uh
visit uh our website
build.envidia.com explore speech then
you can find more um the available uh
reva models uh in the
website. Here is the more thing uh how
to get started with Nvidia Reva uh quick
starter guide uh developers pro uh
developer forum and uh uh the
fine-tuning guide how to fine-tune our
models in the N uh Nemo frameworks.
Yep. So that's it. Thank you. Thank you
everyone. Thank you.